actually let me ask you a question given
your roots as a journalist yeah
um so yeah talking to a guy you disagree
with that's one thing
what about talking to people
that might be Society might consider
bad unethical even evil
what's the role of a journalist in that
context
so climate change is a large number of
people that believe one thing yeah that
believe another thing
uh it turns out even with people that
Society deems as evil there's a large
number of people that support them
what's your role as a journalist
to talk to them well when I I have
talked to really bad people when I wrote
about the murder of Chico Mendez a
Brazilian
Amazon rainforest activist in 1989 I
interviewed The Killers
um one was in jail several of them were
just ranchers who
you know they had their point of view
they were there in the Amazon rainforest
to
the word in Brazil in Portuguese is
limpar to clean the land you know
they're the bandarantes the pioneers of
Brazil they go into these Frontiers and
tame them like we had in our West you
know and they would bring that up too
they would say to me well you did this
out you know they didn't say you
murdered your your Native Americans and
stuff but they could easily have said
that to and you deforested all your
Landscapes um so who are you to come
down here to but if I didn't talk to
them uh that would be
not a way to do journalism but when you
talk to them did you empathize with them
or did you push back
that's the ultimate question like if you
want to understand
like uh if you talk to Hitler in 1941
do you empathize with him or do you push
back
because most journalists would push
because they're trying to signal to a
fellow journalist right and to people
back home that this me the journalist is
on the right side
but if you actually want to understand
the person you should empathize
uh if you want to if you want to be the
kind of person that actually understands
in the full
Arc of History
you need to empathize I find that
journalists
a lot of times perhaps they're
protecting their job their reputation
their sanity are not willing to
empathize yeah well I think this
happened with Joe manchin I mean I'm not
doing any kind of equation here related
to Hitler go Manchester yes or Trump I
mean Trump I interviewed the guy will
happer I mentioned who was a physicist
at Princeton who thinks carbon dioxide
is the greatest thing in the world and
we should have more of it in the
atmosphere I profoundly disagree on that
point
um but I interviewed him for an hour and
and it was so interesting because he was
trying to kind of rope-a-dope me
into making it about CO2 and climate
because he he's a super smart physicist
and I kind of said let's let's talk
about some other things and we started
talking about education and Science
Education he went on for like 20 minutes
about the vital importance of better
Science Education for Americans he drew
on people he knew from Europe Hungary a
bunch of Nobel Prize winners came from
some some town in Hungary for at least a
couple and he said that he learned their
teachers at any rate we he went in a
long Exposition on that he he then
defended climate science he said we need
more climate science he says I love this
stuff I love the ocean buoys there are
now thousands of them in the oceans
charting clearer pictures of ocean
circulation and satellites and he said
something really important that many
people discount which is we need
sustained investment in monitoring this
planet
uh we let our system we neglect our
systems that just tell us what's
happening in the world and that's
happened over and over again
um so if I had left it if I'd gone into
the terrain of the fight over CO2
some journalist friends might say oh
that was good
mashup you know match up and but I found
these really profound and important
things that I wanted the world to know
about
in the context of whether Trump was
going to have him as a science advisor
and so if I hadn't gone there and a lot
of people if you look back I got
hammered for doing that from even from
Friends
and then later John holdren who had been
Obama's science advisor for eight years
he said I would rather have
will happer as Trump's science advisor
the no science advisor in other words
there's a landscape of things that are
important he recognized that happer is
really smart about defense and all kinds
of things too so it's like you do have
to sort of screw up your ideally screw
up your um courage but then not
necessarily get into the
it's like with the guy in Oklahoma you
know
if you're go in looking for the
differences you'll find them you can
amplify them you can leave
with us
paralyzed sense of
nothing having happened that was useful
or you can find these nuggets there's
everyone is a human being I can't play
the mind game of what I would have said
asked to Hitler
but um
I play that mind game all the time but
that's that's for another conversation
yeah yeah that many in my family
um that have suffered under him
nevertheless he is a human being
yeah and I you know people sometimes
caricature Hitler is saying like that
that's when you mentioned Hitler it's a
conversation all right
but I don't agree I think sort of these
extremes are useful thought experiments
to understand because if you're not
willing to take your ideals to that
extreme then then maybe your ideals need
some rethinking and from a journalistic
perspective all that kind of stuff a
number of years ago my wife and I were
with our veterinarian who was
german-born
Dr Bach b-a-c-h we were talking about
the dog and stuff and then we were
talking about Trump and
and he just mentioned in passing he said
my mother voted for Hitler
wow that hit me like a brick yeah
because it was so yeah these at the very
least understanding how
Pathways that lead to
people doing things like he did and
ordered it's essential and the only way
to understand that is to
dig in and ask questions and get
uncomfortable that still makes my hair
prickle when I think back to him saying
yeah my mom voted for Hitler I somehow
makes it super real like oh yeah yeah
wow yeah there's elections There's real
people living their lives and exactly
struggling with a broken economy and
all kinds of having their own little
personal resentments and all that kind
of stuff